If you ask a disagreeable person what,
what he wants say or she wants,
they'll tell you right away.
They know.
It's like,
this is what I want and this is how I'm
going to get it.
But agreeable people,
especially if they're really agreeable,
are so agreeable that they often don't
even know what they want because there
are so accustomed to living for other
people and to finding out what other
people weren't and to trying to make
them comfortable and so forth,
that it's harder for them to find a
sense of their own desires as they move
through life.
And that's not,
not,
there's situations where that's
advantageous,
but it's certainly not advantageous if
you're going to try to,
uh,
forge yourself a career at just doesn't
work at all.
And so even though on average men and
women don't,
this don't,
aren't that much different in terms of
their levels of agreeableness by the
group.
If you go out and you look at the
extremes,
they're very different.
So all of the most agreeable people are
women and all of the most disagreeable
people are men.
And the thing is the extremes are often
what matter rather than what's in the
middle.
And so one of the ways that's reflected
in,
in society by the way,
is there's way more men in prison and
the best personality predictor of being
imprisoned is to be low in
agreeableness.
It makes you callous.
Now you may think,
well,
what's the opposite of compassion and
politeness?
And the answer to that is I think it's
best sort of conceptualized as a,
as a trading game.
So let's say that we're going to play
repeated trading games and if you're a
very agreeable,
then you're going to bargain harder on
my behalf,
then you're going to bargain on your own
behalf.
Whereas if you're very disagreeable,
you're going to do the reverse.
You're going to think,
I mean this trading game for me and you
are going to take care of your own
interests where an agreeable person is
going to say no,
no.
At best,
this is at worst,
this has to be 50 50 but I'd like to
help you every way I can.
One of the things you have to be careful
of if you're agreeable is not to be
exploited because you'll line up to be
exploited.
And I think the reason for that is
because you're wired to be exploited by
infants.
And so that just doesn't work so well in
that actual world.
And one of the things,
one of the things that happens very
often in psychotherapy,
you know,
people come to psychotherapy for
multiple reasons,
but one of them is they often come
because they're too agreeable.
And so what they get is so-called
assertiveness training.
Although it's not exactly assertiveness
that's being trained.
What it is is the ability to learn how
to negotiate on your own behalf.
And one of the things I tell agreeable
people,
especially if they're conscientious
conscientiousness,
say what you think,
tell the truth about what you think
there's going to be things you think
that you think are nasty and harsh and
they probably are nasty and harsh,
but they're also probably true.
And you need to bring those up to the
forefront and deliver the message.
And it's not straightforward at all
because agreeable people do not like
conflict.
Not at all.
They smoothed the water.
You know when you can see,
you can see why that is in accordance
with the hypothesis that I've been
putting forward.
You don't want conflict around infants.
It's too damn dangerous.
You don't want fights to break out.
You don't want anything to disturb the
the relative peace,
you know?
And if you're also more prone to being
hurt physically and perhaps emotionally,
you're also may be loath to engage in
the kind of high intensity conflict that
will solve problems in the short term
because a lot of conflict,
it takes a lot of conflict to solve
problems in the short term and you know
if that can spiral up to where it's
dangerous,
which it can,
if it gets uncontrolled,
it might be safer in the short term to
keep the waters smooth and to not delve
into those situations where conflict
emerges.
The problem with that is it's not a very
good medium to longterm strategy,
right?
Cause lots,
lots of times there are things you have
to talk about because they're not going
to go away.
And the advantage to having a well
socialized disagreeable person is that
they really don't let much get in their
way.
So if you can get a kid who's
disagreeable socialized,
that person can be quite quite the
creature,
you know,
because they're very,
they're very forward moving in their
nature and very difficult to stop.
But if you don't get them successfully
domesticated,
tamed,
roughly speaking by the time they're for
their peers,
reject them.
And that's a big problem because your
job as a parent is to make your child
socially desirable by the age of four.
Like you've got to you,
you want to burn that into your brain
because people don't know that that's
your job.
And here's,
here's why it's easy if you think about
it carefully.
So you imagine you've got to,
you've got a three year old child,
so it's sort of halfway through that
initial period of socialization and you
take that child out in public,
okay,
what do you want for the Child?
Who Cares about you?
What do you want from the Chubb for the
Child?
You want the child to be able to
interact with other children and adults
so that the children are welcoming and
smile and wanting to play with him or
her,
and so the adults are happy to see the
child and treat him or her properly.
And if your child's a horrible little
monster because you're afraid of
disciplining them or you don't know how
to do that properly,
then what they're going to do is they're
going to experience nothing but
rejection from other children and false
smiles from other parents and adults and
that's so then you're throwing the child
out there into a world where every
single face that they see is either
hostile or lying and that's not
something that's going to be
particularly conducive to the mental
health or the wellbeing of your child.
If your child can learn a couple simple
rules of behavior,
like don't interrupt adults when they're
talking too much and pay attention and
try not to hit the other kids over the
head with the truck anymore than is
absolutely necessary then and you know,
and share and play properly.
Then when they meet other kids,
the kids are going to try out a few
little play routines on them and that's
going to go well,
and then they're going to go off and
socialize each other for the rest of
their lives because that's what happens
is that from four years old onwards,
the primary socialization with children
takes place among other children,
and so if the kids don't get in on that
early,
they don't move into that developmental
spiral upwards and they're left behind.
And you can imagine how terrible that is
because a four year old will not play
with another four year old who's too,
but a five year old certainly will not
play with a five year old who's too
right,
because the gap is just starting to get
unbelievably large.
And so the kids start out behind and
then the peers leave them behind,
and then those kids are alienated and
outside the Peer Group for the rest of
their life.
Those are the ones that grow up to be
longterm antisocial,
right?
They're already aggressive.
It doesn't dip down.
Now what happens to normal boys,
roughly speaking?
Imagine that aggressive two-year-old
types,
they get socialized.
So their level of aggression goes down
and then they hit puberty and
testosterone kicks in and Bay levels of
aggression go back up.
And so that's why males are criminals
between the ages roughly of 16 in about
25 so,
and it matches the creativity curve,
by the way.
It's so cool if you look at the spike of
creativity among men,
16 to 25 and it starts to go down,
criminality matches that absolutely
perfectly.
So that's quite cool.
So,
and part of it,
so the testosterone levels raise raise
the average level of aggression among
men.
It's more dominance than aggression
actually in testosterone is by no means
all bad.
And then it starts to decrease at about
age 25 or 26 which is usually would men
stop staying up late at night,
stop drinking as much,
develop a full time career and take on
the burdens and responsibilities and
opportunities that are associated with a
long term partner and family.
And so while,
so that's,
that's the development of,
of,
of I would,
I would,
I would call predatory aggression
because I also think that the,
the agreeableness distribution is
probably something like predatory
aggression versus maternal sympathy.
It's something like that.
So if you look at other,
if you look at other mammals that are,
that are predators,
cause we're predators as well as prey
animals.
If you look at other animals like bears,
the male bear has absolutely nothing to
do with the raising of the infants.
In fact,
the female bears,
we'll keep the mail the hell away
because he's likely to kill the infants
and maybe even to eat them.
So there's no matter analogy at all in
solitary,
male mammalian predators,
it's really useful to investigate the
viewpoints of people who have opposing
views to yours because they'll tell you
things,
not only will they tell you things you
don't know,
they'll also tell you how to see the
world in ways that you don't see it.
And they'll also have skills that you
don't have that you could develop.
So,
for example,
if you're an introverted person,
it's very useful to watch an extroverted
person because the extroverted person
has ways of being in the social world
that aren't natural to you,
that you can use this to improve your
toolkit.
And if you're disagreeable,
one of the best things to do with
disagreeable people,
especially if that's alienating them
from other people,
for example,
because it can,
you know,
people treat you like you're a selfish,
arrogant son of a,
maybe that's because you are,
it's like,
okay,
so what do do about that?
One of the,
one of the most promising treatments,
let's say for that is get the person to
do something for someone else once a
day,
just as a practice and learn how to do
it.
Maybe you can wait the circuit up,
you know,
if you think that it's lying dormant in
you,
which is probably right.
You know,
I think we have a very wide range of
propensities within us.
Some are switched on genetic propensity,
some are switched on.
But I think that if you put yourself in
the right situation or walk yourself
through the right exercises,
you can switch some of these other
things on as well.
But it takes work and dedication and
discipline.
I would say generally speaking,
if you want to adapt yourself properly
to light,
you should find that niche in the
environment that corresponds with your
temperament,
right?
You shouldn't work at cross purposes to
your temperament because it's just too
damn difficult.
But having done that,
then you should work on developing the
skills and viewpoints that exist in the
space opposite to your personality
because that's where you're
fundamentally under developed.
And that way I think you could extend
out your temperamental capability across
a wider range.
And to me that's roughly equivalent,
has bringing a Richard tool kit to each
situation,
you know?
So if you're hyper extroverted,
you should probably learn to shut up at
parties now and then and listen just to
see what's going on,
to see if you can manage it.
You know?
And if you're introverted,
well then you should learn how to speak
in public and to end to learn how to go
to parties without hiding in the corner
and saying nothing to anyone,
you know.
And if you're agreeable,
then you need to learn how to be
disagreeable so people can't push you
around.
And if you're disagreeable,
you learn.
You need to learn how to be agreeable so
that you're not an evil son of a book.
So,
and the same thing applies even in the
conscientious domain.
It's like if you're too conscientious,
you need to learn to relax and let go a
little bit.
And if you're unconscientious it's time.
Like get out the Google calendar man and
start scheduling your day,
right?
And beat yourself on the back of the
head with a stick until you're
disciplined enough so that you can
actually stick to something for some
length of time.
And not living in absolute squalor,
which is something that would
characterize someone who's very
disorderly for example,
cause they just,
they don't notice it doesn't bother
them.
Disorder.
It's like maybe they can see it,
but it doesn't have any emotional
valence.
And so it doesn't have any motivational
significance,
you know?
So the other thing you might want to
think about too,
if you're choosing a partner is try not
to choose someone who's too distant from
you on the temperamental variables
because you're going to have a hard time
bridging the gap.
You know,
it's hard for an introverted person and
an extroverted person to coexist and
it's really hard for an orderly person
and a disorderly person to coexist
because they will drive each other nuts.
Why don't you pick up?
Why are you so obsessed by it?
That's the basic argument,
you know,
so,
so it's useful to know about your
temperament so that you can negotiate
the space with your partner at a wet as
well.
And I don't think you should try to find
someone who is exactly the same as you
because then you don't have the benefits
of the alternative viewpoint,
but you got to watch it because you may
hit Eric concealable differences of
various sorts.
And I've seen that most,
particularly among couples who are high
and low and openness,
that's a rough one.
And also high and low in
conscientiousness.
That's another rough one because they
just cannot see how the other person
sees the world at all.